I had a very general food sensitivity test done. It showed antibodies to coffee and cow dairy.
I don't drink coffee. So how did I get antibodies? Could it be from coffee enemas?
Well, that's that question right away. Yes, you can have antibodies to different foods that come up in
any test. So understand the different tests that are out there are going to test IgG, IgA or IgE antibodies
for foods which that's what they'll be tested for. So those are different kinds of antibodies.
The reason why I like Syrac's test for IgG and IgA on the foods plus it splits out cooked foods
versus non-cooked foods, whether it's been studies that certain foods will be different when they're
cooked versus non-cooked. But if you had a general, you know, like you're saying, food sensitivity test
and it showed positive for coffee, how did I get antibodies to coffee if I don't drink coffee? Let's say
you didn't even ever do coffee enemas, then how would you get antibodies to coffee? Because you've
some food antibodies can have molecular mimics. So let's say you eat a lot of one thing you can actually
develop antibodies to the protein and coffee even though you don't drink coffee because it's a
molecular mimic to something else you have antibodies against. However, in this case, if you're doing
coffee enemas, yes, you're absorbing some of that caffeine and that caffeine is going to be in your
gut. So yes, you could develop antibodies because of that. Do I need to stop them for six months to
heal my gut? Yes, if you have antibodies to coffee and you're doing coffee enemas, you might want to stop
the coffee enemas. I would say three months in retest. I don't for most foods, if you stop eating
that food, if you have antibodies to different foods, for most foods, except the acceptance would be
glued to the dairy. If you stop eating that thing, you will those antibodies, most the time diminish
after two to three months. So I would say just three months and then retest again, though that the
lab might have said six months, I think you'd probably, you know, to finish those antibodies sooner
later. And what can you do if you have antibodies to to coffee and you're doing coffee enemas,
well, I want to keep doing coffee enemas, you can substitute something else for the coffee enemas. You
could do chemical enemas that doesn't have, so you're doing a tea enemah that doesn't have
the caffeine. Now, the purpose of the caffeine is it's going to be a stronger stimulation of the
vagal nerve in the rectal area, but still you can get stimulation of the vagal nerve by using
cannibals. It's just not going to be as strong. So I would just substitute cannibal enemas for a period
of time. Second question is key for an other fermented or cultured dairy okay with antibodies to cow
dairy? Well, no, we don't know. So so typically when you're looking at antibodies to dairy and it says
it's positive for cow dairy, typically they're testing the protein in the dairy, which is KC.
So that's what they're testing. You have antibodies to KC. Now, will the KC be changed
if it's fermented like a kefir or cultured like a yogurt, right? Will it be changed? The answer is
yes, it can be. So when you do a KBMO test, right? And it only tests for cow dairy, but it didn't
test for kefir and it didn't test for yogurt. Well, then we just don't know. And then you're just
kind of back to kind of testing things like what was it? Many times the reason why a person did the
food sensitivity test is because they had symptoms and then they go off of the dairy and their symptoms
start to diminish. And then they would choose to really miss kefir. I'm going to try kefir. I'm going
to go back on that for a couple days and see if my symptoms increase again. And then if they do,
oh, I guess I can't have kefir either. And then I did wait a couple weeks and I'm going to try the
yogurt. Oh, I didn't get any symptoms with the yogurt. So they're able to judge it by signs and
symptoms whether they react to that one thing. It's been very well documented that people
have food sensitivities to dairy, but then they could eat goat's milk cheese and they don't have
your troubles. Or they could eat parmesan or cheese, but they can't eat a soft cheese. They can't
drink milk, but they could have some other form. So the protein in these different
foods can change when it's cultured, changed, can change when they're cooked. So it does get kind
of confusing. And even Cyrex test is still not going to be perfect. Everybody's going to be a little
different, but if you, if it did test positive for dairy and you really want to try to heal your god,
the best thing is to go off all dairy for a period of time and then slowly introduce things back
when you feel like your symptoms are better in order to be able to guide your next decisions,
whether that's working or not.